forty-eight years ago to venerable
scribes set by the names of Jagger and
Richards wrote you can't always get what
you want but you get what you need but
turns out Mickey Keith actually got this
exactly backwards and today it's market
driven economy you can't always get what
you need but you always get what you
want so we need better health care clean
water food security for all climate
change mitigation social equality but
what do we get from the best and
brightest of today's technologists Angry
Birds plants vs. zombies cat videos
photos of your food that will
self-destruct in five seconds and why do
we get these because these are the
things we want of course the breakdown
is these aren't the things that we
really want so one of our challenges for
the future is to be able to better
describe to our markets to our high-tech
products what is it that we really want
now in economics and game theory and
artificial intelligence there's a common
goal of maximizing expected utility and
we spent decades on the expected part
that's desist fixes probability theory
it's machine learning and we spend more
decades on the maximizing part that's
the theory of algorithms as it applies
to all these fields but mostly we leave
the utility part unstated we just take
that as a given and saying that's what
it is that we're trying to maximize well
they never question what it is we
haven't developed the tools to let the
public better describe what they want so
don't just think about data science
information visualization statistical
inference probabilistic reasoning think
also about utility science desire
visualization an ethical calculus build
systems that protect the desires of the
few as well as the many design
algorithms with payoffs that ensure a
sustainable future as well as a
near-term return on investment we have
the power to do many things but until
the public has the power to better say
what it is it really wants the market
will always choose poorly
you